vsauce kevin here the colorado potato
beetle first observed innocently eating
native plants in the rocky mountains in
1811
went crazy when potatoes native to south
america
were introduced to the u.s these beetles
were like wow
potatoes are delicious the beetles were
right
but their potato hunger is so
devastating to crops
entire propaganda campaigns were
launched in world war ii
and again during the cold war claiming
that the cia was
dropping the american bug in places like
germany
and eastern europe as a form of insect
warfare the colorado potato beetle
has been a major potato problem
but potatoes have never been paradoxical
right
wrong enter the potato paradox
it goes like this say you've got 100
pounds of potatoes
and 99 of their weight is water
the other one percent is solid potato
stuff
starches proteins pectins minerals that
kind of stuff
you leave them out overnight and they
dry out a little bit
when you wake up they're only 98
water that would make two percent of it
solid so
how much does your sack of spuds weigh
now
while you think about that let's get
real for a second with
real potatoes not paradoxical ones
so real potatoes are 79
water by weight so i cut this to exactly
100 grams which means
this is 79 grams of water
looks thirst quenching 79 is a lot but
we can go higher per 100 grams
watermelon is 91
water well what's more water than
watermelon
lettuce lettuce is almost 95 percent
water meaning salad is five percent
away from being soup
back to our paradox probably a good idea
to get back to that
probably broke the scale anyway we have
100 pounds of paradox potatoes the
percentage of water weight goes down by
one percent overnight so
their weight today would be 99
pounds a common answer and a good one
if by good you mean
after this tiny change your sack of
spuds
would actually weigh 50 pounds
this 1 shift in composition cuts its
weight
in half how well the easiest way to
visualize the solution
is with potatoes 100 of them
[Music]
oh no no
so here are 100 potatoes
you must hug your potatoes so that they
know that you care
this one painted potato a lovely
space-age silver
is the one percent of solid potato
matter that
we start with the other 99 represent
the water when the potatoes dry out the
amount of
solid matter doesn't change only the
water
goes away so if we remove one unit of
water
we now have 99 pounds of stuff
one of which is dry 98 of which
are water so let's just do a little
calculations here
uh 98 at a 99 is
98 but 0.9898989898989
we don't want all those 0.9 things we
just want 98
okay so that's too much water let's just
remove another water all right so now we
have 97 out of the 98 pounds here
our water so we'll do uh 97
out of 98 and 98.97
is it's too much it's just too much
water
there's got to be a better way
here's the problem this is lowering
really slowly because
for every unit of water that dries away
the total amount that's left
also goes down to see how many we need
to take away
let's look at the final result excuse me
potatoes
okay here's what we got going on here
all right so we need to reduce how much
water we have
not to 98 or 97 but to 49
and here's why so we have 98 percent
water two percent solid but we only have
one solid unit so let's turn that two
into a one so we'll divide two by two
and we get
one so we got to do the same thing now
to our 98 so we'll divide 98 by 2
and that equals 49.
so 49 plus 1 equals 50 and
50 pounds is the answer
so we gotta get rid of so many water
potatoes
i don't know how many are left but it
should be 49 waters
and one solid and 49 divided by 50
is exactly 98
we did it that's the answer the potato
paradox comes into play
every time there are two items and the
concentration of one
doubles that requires the other one's
size to be reduced by half of the whole
whether it's doubling from one percent
or point zero zero
zero one percent or ten percent
ask your friends to solve this problem
and see what they say
most of the time our first response is
to assume that
not much has changed since one percent
is so small
and this isn't something to be ashamed
of our brains
evolve to compare quantities like this
there's one woolly mammoth and there's
five of
us or how much food do we need to
keep the family surviving through the
winter evaluating concentrations
is more abstract and not usually a life
or death issue that natural selection
would play a role
in shaping unlike other famous paradoxes
time travel ones for example the potato
paradox
is a veritable ver
radical paradox
which means it has a true solution we
can all agree on
and prove but is nonetheless surprising
so the potato paradox is a kind of
paradox not built on
misunderstandings or impossibilities or
speculation
but instead is one that really teases
out
how the mind works
now if you'll excuse me i have a vintage
potato toy
to turn into a potato man before he
loses one percent of his water
composition
and half of his weight
and as always thanks for watching
you